[Music]
former president Donald Trump gets a
split decision in the civil case brought
by writer Eugene Carroll who accused him
of raping her in a department store
dressing room in 1996. the nine-member
jury deciding that there was an attack
finding Trump not liable for rape but
liable for sexual abuse battery and
defamation and awarding a total of five
million dollars in Damages to Carol a
verdict Trump's lead lawyer Joe tacopina
calls perplexing strange verdict um this
was a rape claim it was a rape case all
along and the jury rejected that but
made her the findings so we'll obviously
be appealing those other findings Trump
calls the verdict a disgrace in the
continuation of the greatest political
Witch Hunt in history despite several
ongoing investigations he's been the
Republican front-runner in many polls as
he tries to take back the White House
yesterday's verdict in the civil case
comes after Trump was indicted on felony
counts in a hush money investigation
well this is a guy who's been through a
lot of different scandals and
controversies throughout the course of
his political career and he's always
found a way to power through Republican
strategist Colin Reed usually an
unconventional means and methods and
he's got some of the most loyal and
largest followings around of anyone left
right or Center so I'm sure he'll have a
robust response and for someone who's
leading in all of his party's polls and
has had a string of Fairly good
political news in in recent days this is
certainly not what you want to be
dealing with if you're a campaign but
this is a guy who's uh no stranger to
unhelpful political narratives and the
need to fight through them
does this help Florida governor and
potential candidate Ron DeSantis does it
help President Biden
um you know who who are the winners and
losers from this verdict potentially
well on the Republican side there's a
growing contingent of Voters who are
always with the former president and
there's a group who are never going to
be with the former president and then
there's a wide swath of folks in the
middle who are interested in exploring
other options and right now the
overwhelming majority of them are with
Governor DeSantis because he's the most
viable alternative but he's not even an
announced candidate yet and he's had his
challenges as of late and I would watch
those voters because they are apt to
swing to other potential vehicles and
vessels as someone who they who
Republicans believe are best equipped to
replace President Biden uh it's not as
though President Biden's gone through a
good stretch himself the pulley for
maybe seeing the Washington Post that
turned so many heads and I mean those
were abysmal numbers and he's got time
to turn it around but that clock is
ticking
Republican National committee chair Rona
McDaniel says she expects voters to be
focused on issues not investigations I
think a lot of Americans want the focus
to come back to them and the issues that
matter in their lives and they don't
want to continue to see this
investigation after investigation after
investigation that we've seen for now
over six years focusing on issues though
like the border and parents rights and
crime didn't seem to work in the 2022
midterms for republicans
right the 2022 midterms offer a number
of instructive uh lessons to be learned
for the for the party going forward
number one we've got to have a message
that's more than just Joe Biden's
horrible uh voters are seeing that uh
they're already kind of getting that and
they don't need any more convincing on
that they're sold so these candidates
that are forming they're gonna need to
put forward what it is they stand for
and offer voters more than just being
not Biden and not Democrats because we
tried that before and it didn't work out
the way Republicans uh had hoped what
about the current standoff over the debt
limit which is something that the White
House you know has repeatedly blamed on
Republicans saying that they should you
know agree to a clean raising of the
debt limit and set aside the spending
cut debate for after
yeah it seems to me the White House has
been underestimating speaker McCarthy
and his ability to Corral and get his
caucus to pass a piece of legislation
that does raise the debt ceiling uh but
they did the House Republicans acted
they put forward a piece of legislation
they moved the hot potato Court over to
President Biden in the Senate and their
position has thus far been well we're
not going to negotiate I think that's
something that the American public can
see through I don't think anyone wants
to see a default no one wants to see us
go over the the fiscal cliff uh but it's
also becoming untenable just to believe
that the status quo is going to work as
well what about the White House just
hammering this message of extreme
Republicans and mega Republicans
controlling the party's agenda are you
concerned as a Republican strategist
that this is going to resonate with
voters that that is going to stick since
they're hitting it so early and so often
well first it's pretty ironic that the
candidate who pledged to unite America
and bring us all together has now
resorted to just labeling half the
country as extreme but what else can you
do when you've got 36 approval when you
think the 32 percent of Voters believe
you have the mental sharpness for
another four years and 58 of your own
party uh want somebody else to be
nominated as your as your president you
have to attack and disqualify and my
guess is if these numbers continue in
the trajectory they have and if
President Biden isn't able to get into a
better political standing you're going
to start hearing some serious
discussions about some other potential
candidates on the Democratic side
because running as an incumbent with a
46 approval rating that would be
concerning let alone 36 which is if you
believe this latest poll where the
current president is at one other thing
is it fair to say that if it is a trump
Biden rematch that the now president
will be facing a different Donald Trump
in some way because of the multiple
investigations including an indictment
in a hush money case and now this
verdict
time will tell no political candidate if
they're being honest with you wants to
be dealing with legal challenges but
look Donald Trump is nothing if
unpredictable and that's been part of
his appeal but I also think that for the
last three elections from 2018 2020 the
Republican party has not done well up or
down the ballot and uh it's time for
Republicans who want to change from
direction of President Biden to make
that compelling vision for President
Biden the clock is ticking on two key
issues one is the debt limit he had an
oval office meeting with the House and
Senate leaders yesterday but remains in
a standoff over Republican calls to cut
spending the other issue is the surge of
migrants at the southern border expected
to get even worse when the covet era
restriction known as title 42 ends
tomorrow we're doing all we can the
President says it's going to be chaotic
for a while and says that during
yesterday's meeting he raised border
agents as an example of concerns about
spending cuts his approval rating
hitting a new low 36 percent overall in
a recent Washington Post ABC News poll
also sinking among key groups including
black people women and moderates
Democratic strategist and co-host of the
five Jessica Tarlov says that poll has
been an outlier on some fronts but she
acknowledges concern I do think that
overall there have been little messages
that have been coming in especially when
it comes to Ron DeSantis there are a
number of polls from Republican
pollsters like wpea intelligence and
Echelon insights that had President
Biden beating Donald Trump but losing
Tyrone DeSantis in key swing States so
this has kind of been buzzing in their
year and I would always rather run an
election thinking we could lose rather
than it's going to be a cakewalk because
we saw what happened in 2016 and that's
actually the background of the 2022
midterms remember everyone was going on
about this red wave that didn't end up
coming because Democrats took the threat
seriously and made sure that we got out
the vote specifically the youth vote
um so it's serious but I don't at all
feel like the Democratic campaign is
doomed what about his support among
Democrats among Independents for
instance though you know to the extent
that he may have some wobbling there for
lack of a better term I mean what can
his campaign do about it because if he
tries to cater too much to the center
could he then risk losing more votes
from certain groups
so I tend to think that it's unclear or
hard to predict what will cause
President Biden to lose any supporters
until we know who's on the other side of
this because if it's Donald Trump it's
just a very different game than if it's
insert generic Republican and I happen
to think that most of these generic
Republicans have gone really off the
deep end in terms of moving to the right
but you know that around DeSantis is
going to hold differently than a Donald
Trump is just with how polarizing Trump
is so there's always a danger of losing
voters but it really is dependent on
what the Republicans do on the other
side so all of the whatever policy
positions they end up coming with I
think are is going to be really
determinate of who will stick with
President Biden or who might shift over
to the Republicans the president is
facing some democrat criticism at least
from Senator Joe manchin over the over
the debt limit standoff
do you think you should be doing
anything to handle it differently
so I was in favor of taking the meetings
like always take the meeting right
that's what anyone tells you there have
been Democrats who worked in the Obama
administration because remember Obama
negotiated once and he had a shutdown
once and I think it was Dan Pfeiffer
said that having the shutdown not
negotiating was actually the better
approach to it they ended up getting
more of what they wanted when it was
eventually negotiated because they
showed that they were willing to do that
now I don't know if the American public
is going to feel the same way about it
and I would still entertain proposals
that are coming out of the GOP
conference but the things that they're
putting forward are not with anything
that he would sign Republicans are
calling the situation on the southern
border a crisis they have for a long
time the White House says it has a
robust plan for the end of title 42
while also essentially blaming the Trump
Administration and Congress for the
state of the immigration system how much
could a new influx of migrants
hurt the president though and I ask that
in part because there's a new Reuters
ipsis poll where only 26 percent approve
of the president's handling of
immigration so it seems like he you know
he's getting some blame even if the
White House says it's not his fault
yeah and I I mean I always thought that
that was an absurd tact to take um title
42 which was a public health emergency
obviously we are past that thankfully
did serve a good function in terms of
holding people back
um and he will get blamed for this the
question will just be whether this issue
actually matters to voters come November
2024 I think it has the potential to at
the very least be a good talking point
for the Republican side and you know
sitting on a big humanitarian disaster
is no good for anybody obviously for the
people involved and then for the
president politically one thing that
hasn't seemed to affect the president so
far is the hunter Biden investigation do
you think enough voters will ever care
enough about that for it to make a
difference in the election or is it
baked in
oh I don't think that they're nearly on
the scale of the kind of baked in issues
that President Trump has and that there
could be more to come but I don't think
that they're comparable in terms of the
hunter Biden Saga affecting the
president unless a straight line is
drawn from what Hunter Biden was doing
to the president
um I don't think that it'll make any
difference to the American public and
honestly people are just so turned off
by politicians in general I don't think
that anyone really believes in the
character of them all that much which I
think is a very sad reality but it's the
reality nonetheless while I have you I
just wanted to touch on Senate races
there are predictions already again of
an uphill battle for Democrats how can
Democrats win in States like West
Virginia Ohio Montana Arizona you know
what what do you envision as key parts
of the strategy for Democrats West
Virginia is going to be really tough and
I talked about this a lot around the
midterms that we desperately needed the
wins that we got because looking ahead
the 2024 map was just terrible and we
have some of the best candidates we
could hope to run like a John tester in
Montana Sherrod Brown who's been I think
the only if one of two successful
Democrats in Ohio which is basically a
red state so I'm very worried about the
Senate map I think that the Democrats
could regain the house but uphill battle
is a very generous way to describe what
will be going on in the Senate
chance the guitar love co-host of the
five and Democratic strategist thank you
so much for your time yeah thank you for
having me